now at this point i can only laugh now
this is gonna be a little bit more
difficult for me to hide
so i thought i'd just share it so y'all
not asking any questions jada pinkett
smith is getting candid about her
struggles with alopecia we just always
want to have just real conversations and
it doesn't get more real than jada's
message on tuesday taking to instagram
to explain the side effects
y'all know i've been struggling with
alopecia
just all of a sudden one day
look at this line right here
look at that
look at that
and so it just showed up like that
according to the red table talk host the
purpose of the video is to get ahead of
the fan reactions now this is going to
be a little bit more difficult for me to
hide
so i thought i'd just share it so you're
not asking any questions but remember
this is jada we're talking here and
she's got a plan but you know mama's
gonna put some rhinestones in there
and i'm just gonna make me a little
crown
that's what mama
jada's announcement continued in the
caption writing mama's gonna have to
take it down to the scalp so nobody
thinks she got brain surgery or
something me and this alopecia are going
to be friends period the message follows
a sweet mother-daughter moment back in
july when jada and willow smith revealed
they were rocking matching buzz cuts
jada shared this pig to instagram and
wrote willow made me do it because it
was time to let go but my 50s are about
to be divinely lit with this shed
even for me it was a mixture of a
spiritual calling and also going girl at
some point your hairline's gonna be back
here so we might as well just just just
do it now leading up to the actress's
milestone birthday in september and with
help from tiffany haddish jada kept it
real about how empowering it was to
shave her head what did it will say when
you cut your hair off how did he respond
he has sent me a picture of you i know
he's done it you look good i love it
it's been such a freeing i mean so much
just lifted off of me it just called me
i was like the time is now and of course
this one
she's like just do it mom just been
acting you've been wanting to do it for
so long i was like you would just look
so good with just
completely and it's gorgeous
there has been so much uncovering on
this journey that we've been on with red
table talk and i feel like my
the part about the whole process that i
cherish the most is just getting to know
the women in my life in a more
just a deeper way and getting to really
know them as not just my grandmother and
not just my mother but as the individual
women that they are that's kind of how
it started her asking
mom you know i want to know you and not
just you as my mother i was like
right
[Music]